Now going back to the 3 pricing schemes for the 3 different cleaning solution
companies, we want to figure out how much each of these solutions would cost
Grant's cleaning glasses company if he were to buy them. You're going to want an
equation for each solution option so that he can compare how much he would spend
depending on how many gallons of solution he wants to buy. Let's start by
creating a general word equation that we can use later to create specific
equations for each of these brands. Here are some quantities. Gallons of
solution ordered, price per gallon, shipping time, total cost, rush order fee,
and distance shipped. I'd like you to place the letter corresponding to one of
these quantities in each of these boxes. To create an equation that you think
fits a situation Grant is up against.